did you realize that the great majority
of hypothyroid cases like 90 percent up
to 95% as hashimoto's that's interesting
let's talk about first what Hashimoto's
is and then then we'll talk about the
why you have the hypothalamus up here in
the brain that's the master gland that
then talks to the pituitary which is
like the middleman and down to the
thyroid so we have this communication
network it's a feedback loop so you have
the pituitary that releases thyroid
stimulating hormone okay and that has
two purposes one is to tell the thyroid
to release more hormone and to increase
the growth of the thyroid itself so
what's happening is either there is a
low t3 or t4 going on somewhere in the
body that is failing to send back
signals to the pituitary and
hypothalamus causing these two to tell
the thyroid to make more hormone okay
and get bigger or there's an immune
problem which is creating inflammation
which is interfering in this feedback
loop coming from antibodies that are
actually attacking the thyroid itself so
Hashimoto's is an autoimmune condition
which means that there are cells that
are attacking the thyroid and that keeps
the thyroid inflamed so Hashimoto's is
more of an immune problem than a thyroid
problem and the best way to test for it
is to get a test that's called thyroid
peroxidase antibodies TPO a B or T G a B
so you can actually have these tested
and if it shows positive then chances
are you have a Hashimoto's problem now
the three symptoms for this are stressed
anxiety depression but you could pretty
much have any thyroid symptom but what's
weird is when you have Hashimoto's you
can also have symptoms of
hyperthyroidism and some people that
have Hashimoto's hypothyroidism don't
really present with those symptoms that
you normally see in hypothyroidism maybe
they're really really thin they don't
have problems with their hair but they
may have these symptoms right here now
sometimes this condition takes a long
time to
you may show positive for these but not
have any symptoms for 10-15 years so it
takes a while to develop but really it's
an immune problem so the big question is
what is causing this okay what's behind
this well there's a couple interesting
things number one there's a high
percentage of people with Hashimoto's
that develop it three to eight months
postpartum okay and there are five to
eight times more women than have this
condition then men so what does this
tell us this tells us that there's a
problem with estrogen okay now what is
it about estrogen that's related to this
estrogen is a very very powerful
antioxidant this is one of the reasons
why women live longer than men because
this acts as an antioxidant and they
have less free radicals in their body
and many times postpartum which is after
pregnancy she's going to have lower
amounts of estrogen and that could
create a weakness and set her up for
getting this autoimmune condition
another reason why you may develop an
autoimmune condition even to the thyroid
which involves gluten because gluten
tears up the colon lining and it allows
for a leaky gut and allows for proteins
to get into the immune system and create
a reaction and you can actually develop
an autoimmune just from that a couple
other things that contribute to this
problem a zinc deficiency zinc is one of
the most important trace minerals for
the immune system to protect the person
from all sorts of immune problems if
you're deficient in zinc your risk of
getting sick the way up your chances of
having viruses come out of our mission
go up as well also low vitamin D vitamin
D is involved in the immune system so if
you're low in vitamin D you're more at
risk for Hashimoto's so we have a
combination of potentially low estrogen
which means low antioxidants and low
nutrients and maybe something that
triggered it here but the last and most
important piece of this puzzle is
selenium selenium has a tendency to
reduce these antibodies it also is a
very
powerful antioxidant and it helps a
conversion from t4 to t3 the active form
of thyroid hormones so it can really
benefit someone's with Hashimoto's and I
would recommend taking right around 300
micrograms per day of selenium for sure
now you don't necessarily need iodine
unless you're deficient okay so get a
test for that because if you take too
much iodine that I could aggravate
things this is not really an iodine
deficiency problem the other thing
that's really really important to do is
of course how thick Ito and especially
intermittent fasting why because when
you do in a minute fasting and you lower
your carbs you drop inflammation but if
you can get rid of the inflammatory
response from Hashimoto's you get rid of
the complications from Hashimoto's and
you can actually feel much much better
all right so go ahead and try these
things and comment below and thanks for
watching if you're liking this content
please subscribe now and I will actually
keep you updated on future videos